- [Voiceover] Hello grammarians.
So I've talked the idea of verb tense,
which is the ability to
situate words in time,
but today I'd like to
talk about verb aspect,
which is kind of like tense, but more so.
Let me explain what that means,
so with basic verb
tense, we can distinguish
between the present, the
future, and the past,
right, so now, later, then, right,
past, present, and future,
so I could say, simply, "I walk",
"I will walk",
and "I walked",
so this is the past, this is the present,
and this is the future,
so that's verb tense,
but what's really cool about verb aspect
is it's this tool that really allows us
to expand all the possible ways
of expressing something in time,
so you could just say "I walk", true,
but you could also say "I am
walking" or "I'm walking",
or you could say "I have walked"
or
"I have been walking".
All of these things are different aspects.
They're different versions
of the verb to walk,
in the present tense,
and we'll explain all of the those.
They'll each get their own video,
but I just wanted to impress upon you
the idea that within every tense,
past, present, and future,
that there are also
four mini tenses, or baby tenses,
and this is what we call aspect,
and we'll get to the names of those later.
Don't worry about that now.
I just wanted to just plant the seed.
You can learn anything.
David out.